what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to watch
Brooklyn Nine Nine season 4 episode 4
today right yeah that's the one leave a
like you know what to do leave that like
let's just get to it
it's not a secret meeting Jake
it's an intervention the tips have to go
what why Jake we're worried about you
and you look very stupid come on guys I
think they're kind of cool retro are
they gonna shave his head
I'll admit it I went too deep down there
in Florida before we just chop them off
would anybody like to say some final
words no that was one word that counts
thank you Rosa okay I'm ready sorry I'm
late everyone but trust me it's worth it
me and Jake are chip buds what
[Applause]
you know what I do see it it's bad it
looks bad
I always wanted to frost my tips back
when I had short hair I
it's an old new demographic for me to
conquer
Sergeant Jefferson a word
what is wrong with everyone I'm worried
our night shift morale problem has
gotten worse yeah you think
my wife says when I get tired I get
night sassy night sassy hearing problems
much
it's my responsibility to fix this I'm
going to brighten the Mood by telling a
few jokes try this one officers
I don't care for cheese
I'm a curd Majin
you're too tired for humor
it worked for me ever since I moved the
day shift I'm happier healthier my
stepson gave me my debit card back oh
Hank is happy and confident everything's
off oh no we're in the upside down
that's right I'll be back in 40 minutes
what where are you going I have to get
some pens then why are you putting your
jacket off the nearest pen store is
seven blocks away and it doesn't open
until 9 A.M you really think you can lie
to me no ha you're lying to me right now
you do think you can lie to me yep
second under police tape I miss this
oh my God
how low can you go
okay so I am smoking
ah Jacques roses on cigarettes a habit
he picked up from a prostitute Marseille
but
why do all your characters because
they're living life all right
move over to the second case smash
bracelets but then we hear a sound and I
yell at least
and I know what that means because I'm
French but I ask you to repeat it in
English just to be sure yes
flick your cigarette
using the cane he's in the cane this is
awesome
voila
dang great news everyone we just got our
first lead on our first case on my first
night back proving once and for all that
absolutely nothing has changed oh
geez but we're gonna work until it's
done right I mean that's how we do it
yeah I just like to be home as soon as
nikolaj wakes up so I can make him
breakfast goddamn kids not a problem we
will be home by sunup just like a couple
of Sexy Twilight vampires I am Robert
Pattinson I bought the third to do a bat
you're an insult to the books
[Laughter]
can I get you something coffee tea you
know what we're in a bit of a hurry can
you run this DNA for us well of course
sorry not many people stopping by at
night sometimes it makes you like
hahaha
not exactly The A Team at this hour a
team are you guys talking a team I love
that show I could download it we should
binge it this is gonna be fun yep
totally excited to watch five full
seasons of Television run the DNA for us
first kind of feels like you're
prioritizing work over our friendship
because I barely know you fine message
received love when a plan comes together
I was in the bathroom
I'm having stomach problems oh okay all
right nope should have been there I
don't have to hear it
I've been researching ways to raise
morale and I found an interesting
article in a scientific journal
according to a recent study the physical
act of smiling can improve your mood
I've heard this many times
now you're a try
big smiles bigger bigger great
Hitchcock this isn't working out as well
as I'd hoped time for the next level
forced laughing
ha ha ha
now we just got to pull his files from
records yep then we bust him and we'll
be done with plenty of time before
nikolaj wakes up Nicolas Nicolas yeah I
said it Nicolas Nicola almost Nicolas
Nicolas I feel like I'm saying it you
know what it doesn't matter that baby's
gonna ruin your friendship hi can we get
this file please we're in a bit of a
hurry oh absolutely honey
laughs
oh yeah
there we go
oh
my glasses there I was gonna fight for
oh sorry dude I don't know how to get
onto the system I'm a temp may I
great let me just get over here oh good
lord that is porn oh is that not allowed
it is not I'm just
tabs
[Laughter]
got a lot of them
the hell she said she was in the
bathroom again nah she hasn't been to
the bathroom since 8 27. what also ew
come on Hitchcock
huh
who are you Texan
[Laughter]
definitely gonna catch this guy before
setup and you will be home to see your
kid
oh
Jake come on in collage look who it is
remember Jake what a grown-ass kid story
he is real I know you're with your kid
but I checked the file in her perps last
known address is like two blocks from me
I really want to go Jake but I'm here
alone with nikolaj Genevieve does get
back for three hours so let's just take
him with us now that's crazy or is it
just crazy enough to work
do it stinks you got to watch him it's
really messing everything up I mean that
came out wrong I love that you have a
son it's not messing everything up it's
just messing up our ability to solve the
case and have fun you know what I mean
I'm a nice guy I'm in the right
it's an after work hang just trying to
turn up uh maybe we should just name our
favorite sailing knot
the bow line
how about some tunes it's a good one or
favorite sailing
sorry you're all miserable but guess
what so am I I'm exhausted all the time
I never see my husband the late night
NPR programming pure garbage
I saw you earlier you weren't in the
bathroom you were on a park bench
playing on your phone
yeah you left me to do everything well I
thought you were pooping
oh Rosa crying don't know what to do
we put away figures three weeks ago my
mentor should have been back by now we
had plans to meet on that park bench
once the coast was clear he hasn't shown
up maybe he's deep undercover or he
doesn't remember who he is or maybe he's
dead wow
[Laughter]
Jones Tomcat
Smith
Smith
slow down this isn't fair
[Music]
should have shot him yep
I need your Subaru I need to commandeer
this vehicle it's a crossover whoa It's
a crossover SUV and you can't have it
I'm a cop so addition now this is
Schmidt's mom's car and I'm more scared
of her than I am with some two-bit thugs
I'm not a thug I'm police okay the name
one law don't kill people that's me I
set the bar too low look can you please
just
[Laughter]
but who cares about the state's capital
is this the same safe character right
yeah she said Schmitz
new girl's Canon I guess
chasing a criminal your soup is not
important you took an oath to Serve and
Protect that applies to my soup you know
that's not what the oath is about you're
making a point you don't even believe it
damn it
you tell me which is worse my thing very
clearly my thing that's crazy
I love when it shows do that the night
shift stinks stinks like a butt and I
will do everything in my power to make
sure we get back to the day shift what
are we standing around for put some Zeus
on already I want to get wild
you angry at Boyle for having a kid no
I'm just mad because I'm working the
night shift and I have to use a cane and
yes the one thing I could always count
on no matter what Boyle being there for
me is also gone what do you say we let
day shift low hang take a crack at this
I guess I haven't actually spent that
much time with nikolaj yet nikolaj man
am I seriously about to take emotional
advice from low Hank you know you want
to Compadre do it
go to him listen to good Matt Walsh I'll
do your paperwork and if you ever want
company on that bench I'm there thanks I
would advise against it though if he
does come back things are gonna get real
raunchy real fast like I do a lot of
licking that's probably a decent
experience I want to be there yep I
apologize for what well I kept talking
about how I wanted everything to go back
to normal but if that actually happened
this little guy wouldn't be here or is
he big I don't know what size kids are
supposed to be or anything about kids
really I think maybe that's part of the
problem it doesn't matter
I got a present for nikolaj
thanks Jake a truck just like this
almost killed me today uh kiss me
oh my God this is a dream come true I
gotta get my phone I gotta film this oh
but then I'll miss it oh but I want it
forever ah but I should say in the
moment don't forget oh my gosh
no Boyle hang in there
respect mad respect Matt
Walsh respect I've seen every episode of
New Girl really yeah twice dang I like
new girl but I left off
maybe season four
I saw what I feel like people agree were
the the best seasons oh they saw three
episodes years ago oh dude it's a good
show I liked it I just remember watching
what's his name Jake come uh uh oh Jake
Johnson Johnson
Schmidt yeah no uh Schmidt is Max
Greenberg I don't know I don't know how
I remember [ __ ] I don't care
I don't care
uh I just remember for some reason the
name Schmidt always stood out to me yeah
yeah yeah but I've only seen like three
episodes and that was many many years
ago like when it first hit Netflix or
something go back and re-watch
I feel like you would like it nah maybe
what is his name damn not now now I'm
gonna have to IMDb a second thing
oh what they're okay so I wanted I want
to know there the guy who was the tech
looked exactly like a dude we did improv
with for like a brief glimmer in time
and I want to know if it was really him
but uh all right we'll put the video on
pause yes
but uh that character is not listed at
all on IMDb so so we all lost something
today yeah day it was time dalen if that
was you comment below
well what'd you think I enjoyed it it
wasn't maybe the most uproarious episode
of the bunch but you know I mean you
have to have a transition of getting
back in the swing of things and even
though it's not like
the most serial episode coming out of a
very serial Trio of episodes it's still
you know I like I like the personality
of this one and everyone's sort of yeah
being cranky and and what the night
shift is doing to people I thought that
led to a really funny bit with with good
Matt Walsh and uh and two you know Jake
having to come to I've spent the season
feeling like nicolage wasn't real so I
was like cool I like that and I like
this like little the little ways in
which he has to accept that you know
life has moved a little bit since he was
gone and honey collage was a baby
uh uh you know that's a fair thing to
think I didn't think he was real at all
so I didn't bother to think what kind of
child he wanted didn't he get a phone
call when he was
um in prison as a doctor that the baby
was coming or something like that
wasn't adopting I think it was adoption
oh that's right yeah because he was he
had a inhospitable environment yeah so
he is right he couldn't uh okay yeah
that's right that makes sense
I still thought they were adopting a
baby who adopts a grown-ass kid you know
they're a waste of time
if you're thinking of doing it don't do
it you can't really condition them the
way you want to
make them your little slave that way you
can convince them to your biological
child you know what I mean guys that's
the point that's the point yeah yeah
yeah
you know this is an interesting question
at home
tougher and smarter yeah if you're an
orphan if you're an orphan watching this
and you're above the age of six get it
together you know together man you're
gonna be much more badass it's gonna be
easier to pick up chicks yeah totally
yeah you'll have a nice rebellious wrong
side of the tracks backstory you know
yeah this makes me wish I was an orphan
that's right all cool superheroes are
orphans Billy Batson true I'm just
saying man Bruce Wayne's the same being
an orphan is uh it's a gift it is a gift
it is an asset it is a power to be
wielded and um if you suspect you're
adopted don't try to find out because
that means your parents did well sure if
they if they got you at the right age
yeah what I mean yeah totally
um you can't convince someone you pull
them out they already have a brain
that's been developing for a few years
no
I don't know
anyway Let's uh stick that on the wall
put a pin in that and come back to the
orphan
yeah we'll we'll unpack that some more
that's the season I would love to adopt
um that's like one of the most lovely
gifts you can do I get I think how would
you know you know would you possibly
know that's one of the most lovely gifts
you can do because I feel like there's
some clothes
ever in your life you I am an impulsive
person you would be surprised you do you
know something are you friends with
someone
who adopted and you were there for the
process yes to be like oh my God they
just adopted a child I'm gonna go meet
this child totally and I I vetted the
child myself
so I was like I know his personal
experience it was a terrible thing it is
a torture to put Upon a Child to pluck
them and it is a difficult psychological
process and I'm just telling you it's
just it's not worth it why yeah all
you're doing is inviting them I want to
give a kid a life of awkward jokes
people will make without realizing
they're being offensive yeah especially
if you adopt outside of your race you
want to try and get them to look like
you that way there's no question about
it yeah so
I'm just part of Me Part of Me Now is
sitting here going what is the real
ethics of that unless you're rich you
know then you can give them a really
something something really special if
you're rich and then Plus
public wise that looks great it is a
good it's probably a text write-off too
it's a good tax write-off and uh makes
you look humbling not like all these
other celebrities
yeah I'm waiting until the channels of
two million Subs then adopting and dude
you could have them monetize that kid
too my guests start a kid Family Channel
make the kid edit those videos monetize
the [ __ ] out of that child
ways to do it ways to adopt yeah um that
financially benefit you but uh we again
another time
the the yeah I thought the episode was
really fun yeah oh John's uh begrudging
attitude towards this episode is no it
was really fun it was one of those
episodes where I wasn't like defying
every joke but I loved the mood the
falling because I don't know like a good
guffaw like
you know that's an actual word falling
I've never heard that word
okay
yeah that's a common word
it definitely already used in many
sentences totally over I mean I guess uh
it probably showed up a lot in Harry
Potter or something
did it
in the books I would imagine maybe those
were the most consistent uh you know the
most consistently I would have dipped
into the same literary voice and thus I
could imagine maybe I maybe it was used
there and uh damn but if I it's it's an
older word it it's a it's a more
Antiquated term for laughter it's more
Arcane if you will a bit archaic even
retro vintage
oh
yeah there we go it's lost until
we got there
stupid
um anyway yeah uh I thought that the
episode was
um
so it was not a filter fish
those bloopers boy it was not a Gravity
Guy it was not Gravity Falls China
nice to meet you
yeah Nick Miller that's his name I
didn't even need to get the Google
search It's Jake Johnson's name and the
new girl he's Nick Miller and I really
cared anyway continue on so
falling yeah I think the Amy storyline
was nice I felt like it had something to
do with Jason manzukas that was a it was
kind of heartbreaking I like whenever we
get to see a more sensitive inside of
Rosa feeling far between but you know
when you're reminded that Stephanie
Beatrice can cry on camera the mark of
any good actor aren't many good reactor
too it's funny because in that moment I
was going oh wow she's she's really
committed to this but I'm like
I guess it wouldn't be good if you
wasn't I guess like because it's a
sitcom you're surprised but yeah she was
great that was funny I think Holt being
trying to be Captain who's trying to be
like a funny
fun fun leader in the department at
uplift morale was hilarious but uh Andy
Samberg to me it's still like really is
like the Andy Samberg
the Jake can hold [ __ ] it really there's
so many ways it is the Jake and Holt
show and it's just like his antics of
just escalating and trying to keep you
under control and his difficulty growing
up is it's a consistently funny thing to
me
and yeah I have plenty of friends now
I've had kids
and uh cousin who has a kid
not adopted not adopted the way you
should do it and
you heard it here folks
so if you were considering it now you
know
um
and um you know if you find offense of
that sorry
but if you're someone who actually
is adopted you're probably not offended
because you have thick skin
[Laughter]
and if you don't know you're adopted
then you're none the wiser to anyone
subconsciously you know
around the family you know something's
all right
I know
I'm a Targaryen I'm I'm definitely a
Targaryen and a Valerian
um they're not adopted
that's true
I'm not work not an example no no it did
not work that joke I'd take it back
stricken it from the record your honor
it's so
um
oh my God what are we talking about we
were talking about
um the Jake and Holt Dynamic yeah
whatever it's fine and then to end funny
enough they didn't did they really
interact at all in this episode like I
thought that was no no I think there was
tensions on set and they wouldn't allow
them to interact in the same room keep
them a part or a fight's gonna break oh
yeah but it was it was really fun and
nice to get some of that as much as
there is the tension of nicolage it was
nice to get some of that classic uh
Samberg and and Le triglio together Le
trulio however you say his name
get get some Jake and Chuck
yeah next one's the Halloween episode
though it's right I'm excited it's gonna
be a heist I assume do you know this
already well isn't that the tradition
isn't always the Halloween Heist of some
kind
or is the heist a different no it's it's
a Halloween Heist I'm sticking in my
guns
as Canon
all right guys listen uh we did our part
we're done so thanks for being here Zoe
Deschanel showing up is nice
my mind was doing some work there
I was like oh is this like a celebrity
guest star or was she not a celebrity
yet
and then it took me a few minutes of
minutes uh like moments to be like wait
a minute Schmidt
New Girl that's the same one yeah and
then when I was about to say that I saw
your face looking weird and I was like
oh is that same one yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was like a one-two punch it was
like whoa wait like this is a little
late for for special guest star Zoe de
Chanel whoa whoa wait what this is
context of a holy other show but I guess
they were both on Fox
that's smart so that's cool because new
girls on the west coast right so like
maybe there was an arc at the time where
she's visiting New York I can't remember
or is it in they live off like the beach
don't they I don't know
I I gotta see it again I gotta watch the
show it's about like three guys trying
to banger
uh at some point and then it graduates
at least one of them is trying it's
trying to bang everyone and then one of
them is trying to romantically you know
over much time
bang her I don't see the appeal I'm
sorry
[Laughter]
or or of the premise of New Girl
uh you know manic pixie to go watch I've
never seen 500 Days of Summer but go
watch that I'm sure
yeah I get it bubbly and quirky but also
it's pretty
she plays a scientist in The Happening
no a teacher Mark Wahlberg's a scientist
much more believable
I'm going to teach you all about physics
okay
anyway
um why are you eyeing my lemon drink
I know buddy I'm sorry for everything
that's ever happened in your life
things could be much worse to be honest
what's in the cat
all right guys we're good we're done
Brooklyn nine nine
[Music]